and the brilliant brilliant Camp of Izzy
and his coach who's absolutely one of
the best to do it they were smart enough
to go if we can pull out and get him to
get comfortable and start throwing not
just one shots one shots we can't really
counter it's tough to land a big shot
but we can get him to throw combinations
against the fence give them Close
Quarters so then we can exchange and
land one we can get them out here under
five rounds that's what they did the old
rope-a-dope
through the city like
[Music]
oh London
what's up there Monday morning April
10th welcome to the show how was your
Easter did your kids eat that chocolate
rabbit butt first or ears first says a
lot about your child mine ain't ass
first
what can you do I don't know what that
says about them but it's going to pay
off down the road eating that chocolate
bunny booty first uh so happy uh belated
Easter day happy uh I'm gonna say
Thanksgiving Happy Easter we had quite
the Advent we had quite the event go
down Saturday night UFC
287 was everything we hoped for wasn't
it it was fantastic uh depending how you
bet depending uh who you favor in
certain matchups your heart was either
broken or you're just so freaking happy
like the rest of us
um it was just an overall great card
from top to bottom they do have a good
card this Saturday it's a fight night I
think it's at 5 p.m Pacific you have Max
Holloway and uh Arnold Allen which is a
great fight that's in Barbosa and our
boy Billy
cornantillo fighting you have Dustin
Jacoby uh Pedro Munoz clay Guida then a
[__] throwback at her Germans on that
Brandon Roy vows on the prelims how dare
you so uh yeah UFC is a boom and UFC is
a cooking but going back to the main uh
dish UFC 287 let's jump right on in kids
um man what so many story lines on this
what we'll get into the uh the main card
right away here uh I see a lot of uh
concerned fans with the Michelle
Waterson uh Luana decision there
um a lot of people think Michelle was
robbed you know I'm a Michelle Fan so I
agree with you guys what I tell you
about Joe Pfeiffer what I tell you about
him on the fan question you guys are
asking about it and I said if you were
to handle Gerald mershart who's kind of
always like lingering around the top 15.
he wins that uh he should fight the
winner of Kelvin gasum Chris Curtis I
think it should be Joe Pfeiffer versus
Calvin gaslin next uh Pfeiffer is the
real deal Holyfield there at a pencil he
is a Savage training with Sean Brady
that kid's ready for the big show as you
can tell he absolutely Molly wopped
Gerald Mercer which is not an easy thing
to do uh but with the main card let's
kick it off Christian Rodriguez Raul uh
Rosa Jr what did I tell you on Monday if
you listen to the show and if you listen
to the fight Campaign which is available
right now if you want to see the whole
fight man geovera crushed it was so much
fun
um just a good time best show that I do
but if you listen even before this fight
happened I was breaking down for Sam uh
Cheeto and Cal and that this isn't a
gimme fight for Rosa JR this is a very
tough fight Christian Rodriguez uh even
on the local circuit was known as like
the next guy
um in his gym he was like Hey this kid
has world champion written all over him
even on his Contender series fight he
Molly wopped the dude but he missed
weight so they didn't give him the green
light but not a great matchup I told you
guys this was gonna be a tough test I
still did pick uh Rosa Junior to pass
the test
um you know and you don't want to uh
beat up a kid especially at 18.
and it's not uh Rosa Junior's fault you
know because at 18 you know the world is
your oyster and you feel uh as if you're
untouchable but that's why you have
older more mature adults around you that
can can try to kind of control those uh
emotions and certain things that you say
or feelings because Rosa Junior should
feel that way at 18. that's exactly how
you should feel being undefeated
um but after seeing a skill set
um especially in the Striking Department
I think it'd be tough for anyone to
defend him being the UFC right now at
18. I don't think he landed he yeah I
don't can you bring up the numbers in I
don't think he landed anything
substantial on the feet I also don't
think he really threw anything on the
feet the first round
yo grappled the guy's wrestling's
position was uh you know of professional
level but outside that
um the kid has a ton of work to do now
this is a young man and rightfully so he
should be saying this when I was a young
Fighter coming up after my second major
professional fight I called out Frank
mayor and Josh Barnett I was crazy you
need somebody to tell you hey dude it's
a marathon not a Sprint
um so if you look at it so round one uh
he threw zero uh round two he threw zero
and round three he landed two punches
that's a problem that's a problem
because at this level and especially
don't get around his grappling is solid
it's good it's not Arnold Allen good
it's not you know khabib good or uh you
know a lot of these other dagestanians
bone nickel these real outliers that are
absolutely going to tie you in knots uh
from the the moment the bell rings so
I'm just on the end of
don't get the experience in the UFC get
it outside the Octagon because once
you're in the FC there's not a lot of
easy matchups like I think maybe the UFC
thought this kid was ready for the Big
Show and to the UFC's defense
listen you gotta take some shots you
know shoot or shoot and you'll see shot
before and sometimes they knock out of
the park and then sometimes
um you know unfortunately it's at the
consequences of a kid's career it
doesn't go well you look at Sage
Northcutt probably push them a little
too soon right he had dealt with uh
Paige VanZant was very very tough
um you know there's a dentale even
though he didn't come up like these guys
but it was still a little too much too
soon being the main event against
Woodley in London
um and then after that you know you
don't want to get the experience and you
see dirt until might be a bad one
because he did have a lot of experience
outside when he got there I'm saying the
point is if you push someone too fast it
has dire consequences especially when
they're 18 is the point here when you're
18 to lose like this and realize that
you're not Untouchable kind of changes a
Fighter's path so for Rosa Junior it's
okay to lose an MMA he shouldn't hang
his head the ish she was at 18 this
early in your career was he seven and
one eight and one now so you don't have
a ton of fights you don't have a ton of
big moments in your career there's a
reason why boxers are 30-0 25-0 45-0 by
the time they really face any adversity
because if you look at like a guy like
Mike Tyson
or there's other examples where they
they need to get to a certain level
where they actually think they're God's
Gift of fighting and they go in there
with that mindset thinking they can pull
anything off but that's done through
actual fighting it's not done through
words your coaches tell you that or your
training Partners telling you that you
actually got to get it done inside that
out gun or inside that ring through
years of experience and what Rosa Junior
was saying oh you know in under a year
I'll be the next World Champion I don't
have a problem with anybody saying that
and I would imagine that anybody at that
135 pound weight class is saying the
same thing maybe not out loud but
everyone feels that way just let you
guys know every single person you saw a
fight on Saturday night thinks they're
gonna be world champion nobody gets the
UFC and goes I just want to be a 500 guy
I just want to win three maybe lose one
this should be a perennial top 10 guy
nobody thinks like that every single
person's goal is to be a world champion
Rosa Junior just say it said it very
loud and at 18 so I was like oh so you
know you got to pump the brakes but he's
he's saying the right things the right
mentality the problem is you put so much
pressure on yourself when you do that
the other problem is
is striking is nowhere near anybody at
the 135 uh weight class he's nowhere
near their level so let's say Dig It by
Christian Rodriguez let's say he out
grappled him uh for three rounds and
only through two punches well how many
fights you need FC give him where he's
not gonna where he can just Skip by on
that grappling because again he's not he
again very clear he's not a guy you know
that uh like Brian Ortega even though
Brian has great striking but that goes
to the ground you're in trouble
um Arnold Allen his wrestling is you
know second second to none there's a lot
of guys that have that wrestling
pedigree where they can lean on that and
um you know what we saw at a rose of
June he's just not one of those guys and
eventually you're going to run in a guy
who can defend the takedown and then be
forced to win a fight on the feet and
that makes martial arts and he's so far
from there what we saw on Saturday now
maybe he just had one of the worst
nights ever I get that but even when you
have bad nights like
if you go and watch the fight campaign
what's available right now Cheeto Vera I
said hey when you fought Corey
sandahagan that was not the Cheeto that
I know he was dude I don't want to say
anything you're dead on you're dead
right I was not in the right mind space
just didn't feel like doing it but
there's a difference between not feeling
like doing it and still going out there
and having technique and Performing and
looking like a top five caliber fighter
and there's a huge difference between ah
my body didn't feel ready but I still
went out there but when the technique's
not there that's not a mental thing
that's an experienced thing that's a
fundamental thing and that's when I get
worried that's when I see so the biggest
takeaway for Rosa Junior it's like
you're not even remotely close to
competing at this level you're just not
now I'm not saying you can't be a world
champion UFC you have you have all the
tools you have the mindset you have
hopefully you have the camp it doesn't
sound like he does but eventually you'll
get there but you can definitely still
be championed this could be the best
thing to happen to you because we got to
pump the brakes because as far as your
striking goes it is so far off from
being at a UFC level even for in the the
middle tier guys even the guys ranked 30
and Below you're not even remotely close
to touching them out of striking
technical wise you're just not there
let's take a little break you little
crazy hippos listen I only recommend
products that I actually use this one I
reach out to them because I swear by it
we're talking about happy hippo Kratom
this stuff helps me tackle anything that
I'm doing podcasts stand up just life in
general Kratom is fantastic it's not the
wild west anymore because there's
companies like be hippo where it's
reliable it's trustworthy it's the best
of the best and whether you're looking
for gummies I take the the shots right
here this one is the sour apple shot
that's the Kratom shot it gives you an
instant boost get you right where you
need to be they have butterscotch which
is good but I like the sour apple they
have gummies they have powders they got
any way that you want to get the best
Kratom on the planet talk about happy
hippo go to happyhippo.com promo code is
thick23 you save 20 off the entire site
that's thick t h i c c 23 for 20 off for
life at happyhippo.com this episode of
the shop show is brought to you by the
one the only the Old Faithful on it
we're talking about on it baby the best
nootropic on the planet Alpha Brain now
we all know about Alpha Brain they've
sold over a million bottles of the
regular Alpha Brain but what about Alpha
Brain Black Label that's what your boy
uses I take four pills next thing you
know I'm coming up with all sorts of a
cool experiment that's right I still
trying to figure out how to grow calen's
hair I'm gonna get there and Alpha Brain
Black Label is going to get me there it
helps support cognitive functions
include memory mental speed and focus it
aids in mental processing it's caffeine
free helps you get to that flow State
support your freaking memory remember
names places addresses phone numbers
think more clearly under stress all
right on it also offers the usual
fitness equipment like kettlebell steel
Club Macy's sandbags yoga mats also the
supplements there's none better if
you're trying to get your thick body in
shape let audit help you with their mc2
oils their proteins their Warrior bars
we got it all man go to audit.com schab
and you get 10 off everything I just
listed literally everything Alpha Brain
Alpha Brain instant shot Alpha Brain
instant where you put in eight ounces of
water Alpha Brain Black Label you save
temperatures off everything all right on
it.com now let's get back to the program
but it's glad it happened early you're
only 18 dude you're only 18. the problem
is and this is why we tell you that the
UFC is a marathon not a Sprint now it
gets dicey because now you're in the FC
and the UFC has to kind of shift through
the rank is at 35 look through who's who
on the roster can you beat now because
they've put all this hype into you
um you know and like I said UFC uh it's
the the Brand's bigger than any fighter
so shoot or shoot they help you become a
superstar if you don't on the next guy
and a lot of times they get it right but
when they get it wrong it goes south it
goes really South and at a kid at 18
you just gotta hope that mentally
he can overcome this learn from it get
back on the freaking
you know elliptical and get his mind
right and start to win more fights but
the glaring hole there is his striking
and um you know this was a tough matchup
for him it's too much too soon we
learned that it's just unfortunate for
him it was on the main card on a major
pay-per-view so I'm sure he's getting a
ton of [__] right now I'm looking to
Dogpile on this kid he still can't be a
world champion it just ain't happening
he said under a year I would say it's
not happening for at least five to six
years not even close so far from the
rest of the competition unfortunately
and that's good for him so he chin just
brought up this article he put my bad
Bros there's a lot of chicks are at this
point too my man uh I didn't have the
energy to do what I know or even try
things happen for a reason God knows my
opponent was better tonight thank you
guys
um then Dana said it happens he's a
young kid
um
I had uh two rounds of one yep he's got
a lot of growing to do a lot of work to
do nobody really goes on defeating the
sport it's very very hard to do yeah I
never expect to go undefeated I just
expected his striking to be a lot more
high level especially when you get to
the UFC than what it was so when we say
he has work to do he has all the work to
do it's a ton of work but I think he's
up for the challenge again he is Young
he's only 18. it's better this game now
than when you're 30. like if you're 30
and you're striking look like he's like
you should probably just go get a
different job but at 18 and his
grappling look pretty good
we can work with some stuff there just
on the main card also probably not in
the UFC he loses the next one you should
probably go get some more experience
outside Lucy and then at 18 you can
always come back it's all good he has a
fan base he's there but that striking is
tough Uh Kevin Holland looked fantastic
he knew that win so bad the
disappointing part about marswood all
losing is a
uh we don't get the Maslow Kevin Holland
fight which I would love
even though Kevin Holland won that would
still be a huge fight for Kevin Holland
and it'd make a lot of sense for Jorge
Maslow because they had so much
animosity outside the Octagon on the
streets which you know the street
soldier gets it done with Jorge uh but
also
um Leon Edwards you know tweeted out was
man Jorge messed up the bag so by Jorge
losing it really kind of [__] over Leon
Edwards because remember Leon doesn't
want to fight Colby the only thing that
caveat there were like oh why wouldn't I
do it why wouldn't he want to do it
Kobe's the next guy in line besides
Camaro Usman who land just beat so Kobe
makes sense but for Leon there's the
story of Jorge and him in London and the
two-piece and a soda or whatever the
hell it was so that narrative was there
for Leon it's a much easier matchup than
Kobe or Blair Mohammed or any of these
other guys coming up so I think Leon was
banking on that it's an easier Payday
for him it's a big fight be in London
can't do it now that's out the window so
now I think by Jorge losing he's forced
to fight Kobe Covington who else can he
say no to you know so I think UFC is
going to force his hand now because I
think UFC was kind of open to it
especially if Jorge won in dramatic
fashion to be like yeah Jorge's the guy
he's gonna sell a ton of tickets make us
a lot of money we're in the business of
making money not making the best fight
so let's do it but Jorge law so that's
out the window so it kind of [__] over
not over not only Kevin Holland but also
[__] over Leon Edwards but um yeah
Kevin Hahn looked fantastic he was at a
fork in the road uh pontoon the bummer
about to nebio is he said he was gonna
you know
uh talk to the commission about
overturning the fight said he gave a
thumbs up he wasn't out that is not true
in any facet he was definitely out so
he's lost one two three four out of his
last six so it gets tough man
it gets tough for that guy
um but Kevin Hall needed that win and
Kevin Han's such a character so he's
good for business
um the most surprising thing which
I don't say surprise and I called I said
it was gonna be fire the night it ended
way earlier than I uh anticipated Rob
font versus Adrian Yanez
um Yanez is is my guy I love I love Rob
but you know Adrian I absolutely love
Adrian I like when a prospect's coming
up and passing the test I just think
this was again this it's not the UFC's
fault but you know sometimes you gotta
[__] or get off the pot for Adriana as
you should get off the pot against the
number seven guy in the banterweight
division Rob font style Escape just
didn't make a ton of sense for Jana's
take this fight
um it's just he has a lot some work to
do so this is different right so with
Janez
you can see the techniques there the the
skill set is there he has every box
check to be world champion in the future
you decide to play a dangerous game with
a dangerous vet and Rob font who hits
like a Mack truck has big hands lands
more shots even when he loses fights but
he's always hurting people and Adrian
Giannis does get hit the problem is is
he hasn't been hit by a Savvy vet like
Rob font and once Rob smells blood in
the water he's gonna finish you off this
is what happened Adrian Yanez he just
decided to play that dangerous game if
that uppercut landed a little sooner he
could defend himself from that right
hook which knocked him out but he missed
it's a game of inches he gets knocked
out all good you tested your you know
you test the waters in the top ten
you're not ready for it all good
all good if that's a bet on who's going
to be a world champion between Adrian
and uh Rosa Junior my money's on Adrian
because I can you can see the skill for
Rosa there's so many questions he has so
much work to do and uh agents with a
great Camp he's beat some great guys
already uh not great but he's definitely
beat the [__] out people he said
performance of the knights fight the
knights so he's must see TV but with
Rosa Junior there's just so much work to
do there I wouldn't co-side him being
world champion anytime soon but Adrian
you can even though it's a setback
complete disaster
um took a match up in the top ten so I
was off on Rosa I was off on Jana's
um and then the co-main event Gilbert
Burns hoary maswood all I told you guys
also you're crazy if you think Corey was
just gonna lay down on his last fight
and just let Gilbert mop the floor with
him even though Gilbert was a plus uh
400 or minus 400 I thought that was a
little disrespectful it's Jorge Mazda
meant so his takedown defense fantastic
um I didn't think he was Gilbert Burns
best showing I thought you looked good I
just don't know what it does for Giller
either and I know Gilbert said either
they give me a tile shower Tire
you know I don't know if UFC is going to
do that you know
um Colby Covington's right there yeah
Muhammad right there
um shafkot you know and moham is
supposed to fight so for Gilbert he's a
little bit on the outside looking in
there but because they're guaranteeing
Kobe Compton the title shot so it's a
little dicey then he can't fight Kamara
Usman they fought right we've seen that
um A lot's going to be predicated on
what happens that welterweight division
you get Leon versus Colby in London and
then you're gonna get uh shopkat and um
Muhammad and the winners of that it's
definitely going to make it a clear
passage to the title shot and who's next
stuff like that so A lot has to happen
that division for us to get a better
understanding of what's going to happen
there
um and then in the main event my God
my Lord Izzy adesanya what can you say
man we can say we've never seen it
before
we've never seen a guy at his age lose
the belt uh with a guy who's had his
number he's 3-0 against them
um but I think that's what makes Izzy an
outlier is
you know he doesn't predicate his life
based off history every stat that you
could find in the UFC would show that
Izzy's was going to lose this fight
every stat even though oddsmakers had
him a slight favorite because if you
watch the fight she can say man if Izzy
just did a few things different he's a
better mixed martial artist than Alex
Pierre hands down it's there's no debate
he just bet he has more tools he doesn't
hit as hard but outside that outside
hitting hard he does everything better
in Knox Pierre he's not as big doesn't
hit us hard he's won more rounds even in
the ring and the Octagon is he if he
just changes the tweaks a few things
here you should be able to pull this off
um and on the questions that we posted
last Thursday the fan question said Can
Izzy get it done via kale I said
absolutely
absolutely because in the first fight
they had in the UFC he mollywapped them
almost had him out on his feet in the
first round so we know Izzy does have
that power he has the capabilities we
just need octopia to play that game that
gives Izzy the chance to get it done and
the brilliant brilliant Camp of Izzy and
his coach who's absolutely one of the
best to do it they were smart enough to
go if we can pull out and get him to get
comfortable and start throwing not just
one shots one shots we can't really
counter it's tough to land a big shot
but we can get him to throw combinations
against the fence get them Close
Quarters so then we can exchange and
land one we can get him out of here
under five rounds that's what they did
the old rope-a-dope and you know you saw
the boys me and Sam tripley were rocking
the engaged shirt it's so funny because
Izzy has this collab with Muhammad Ali
he pulls the fight off doing something
very similar that Muhammad Ali did the
Rope of dope to lure Alex Pierre and
this is how he changed from the last
fight he realized that for him to hurt
Alex Pierre he has to lure this monster
in he has to play this game with
potentially arguably the hardest hitter
ever in the middleweight division or in
UFC history outside Francis ingano maybe
but even Alex Pierre uh Izzy's coach
said makes no sense the guy has a gift
from God how hard he hits so you got to
play this game where let's lure him in
where he gets comfortable and he's
throwing those combinations and when
he's throwing those combos hands are
down and we can come up to up and land
it's insane that was the game plan but
they pulled it off they pulled it off
you'll never see them fight again I know
people are saying well Izzy's clear out
the division there's nothing else for
him why wouldn't they do it again I'm
telling you mark my words you're never
seeing it again Oxford it's too rough of
a cut the only reason he was cut in 85
is to chase that monster and iziata
Sanya he had the perfect game plan to
beat him he's 3-0 against him the only
reason he was killing himself to make 85
was because Izzy was there as the world
champion now that that's over you're
gonna see him he's a tool fiber that guy
is a bona fide [__] 205 through and
through for God's sakes quit killing
yourself and he's gonna be able to take
better shots at 205. now if you guys do
hit harder there and you know he does
get hit but the benefits at 205 for Alex
Pierre are Limitless the ceiling is so
high for him at 205. you see the way he
matches up against uh Yuri would be he
matches up great against uh Jamal Haley
matches upgrade against racket great
Anthony Swift great Johnny Walker great
Vulcan great you know so you look at all
these Dominic Reyes yeah you go down the
list Dustin Jacoby uh ground tree all
these guys now there's a few guys where
it's like let's avoid those mocking mad
at number two that'd be tough one yawn
it's a tough one I I would probably
favor him over young gotta be honest
unless yon really shot in there and got
him down early on but you know at Pierre
at 205 is going to be a handful for
anybody especially those gentlemen I
left off are listed off before uh all
the strikers I'm
a problem for him but outside that it is
there's so many matchups for him there
it just makes all the sense in the world
so let's pretend that I'm dead set right
and I'll experience at 205. so at
middleweight the problem is with Izzy in
the top five not only has he beat
everybody in the top five but he's beat
most of them twice
there's nobody you want to see there
there's an argument for Robert Whittaker
doing the uh the trilogy but he's too
and all against them last fight wasn't
even close you know knock them out so
the argument there's not great uh I
think for Izzy
um you know the best thing you know he
likes to this what makes Izzy to me the
greatest of all time there's argument
Anderson Silva I have Izzy over him for
a variety of reasons but one thing that
makes Izzy great he usually fights every
about he's a real active Champion which
is unheard of very active fights about
every four months every four months
three times a year he's always fighting
against anybody anybody so for Izzy it's
gonna be a little tough hear me out here
is he I think he needs to sit out for a
little bit have Robert Whittaker and
hamzat fight in the winner of that
whether it's Whitaker or homs that is
guaranteed a title shot against Izzy
there's nothing else to do you can't you
can't and I know if he can do it because
in the business of money and Hamza and
Izzy and the story of Hamza this
Boogeyman at 170 came up to 85 you know
and he's a Grappler and he's just you
know uh monster coming to 85k we can't
sell that but just under principle you
just can't go from 170 not being active
then jump right to a new weight class at
85 and fight the one the greatest
champion we've ever had coming off this
insane win over Alex Pierre you just it
just doesn't make too much sense what
makes sense is hamzat Whitaker you do
that you know that big July card you
have them as a co-main event because you
have uh or you do at the main event
because you have the the co-main event
would be Yaya Rodriguez and uh
volkonovsky so you have the guaranteed
winner of Hamza versus Whitaker the next
tile shot Izzy because if Whitaker were
to beat hamzat then there you go and
that's interesting too because that's
also a hamza's toughest test in the
middleweight division is Robert
Whittaker so he passes that deserves a
title shot dude the hot the build up the
hamzat Izzy if you're the starch Robert
Whittaker would be insane vice versa to
that if Whitaker starches this Boogeyman
this insane Boogeyman if he starts his
uh Hamza and puts a halt to this hype
you tell me you don't want to see Robert
Whittaker come off the huge harms that
win fight Izzy again
but you look at Izzy I don't know what's
really left for him he'd do the
answering thing we jump to 205 even if
it's not for a belt remember he fought
like Forest Bonner and those guys you do
some of that stuff it's the right match
up a yearly fight might make sense a
racket fight even a Jamal Hill I you
know depend what Alex capier wants to do
is he could even go up and he matches up
way better with Jamal Hill than he does
uh Jan blockovich so he could do that
stuff you know there's some outliers
there you do the answer still thing
where you let the division figure itself
out with Robert Whittaker and hamzat
until that gets done you want to stay
active you go to 205 but it has to be
perfect matchups we're not fighting
magomed we're not fighting yawn again
you know then young goes oh I'll cut to
85 boy
son
that's not happening so for Izzy you
know he needs to be chill be patient if
he wants to compete go to 205 with the
right matchups Jamal Hill Yuri rakik uh
Anthony Smith krylov Johnny Walker
ozdamere all the same guys are listed
off for Alex Piero you can play that
game if you want stay active get those
wins then jump back over once Whitaker
and harms out fight that's what I'll do
but man what a story water storing him
now besides car McGregor who's a
complete outlier in any [__] sport
there's not a bigger star in the UFC
than Izzy there's just not there's not
he's the biggest star and this cement to
him is the he's the face of the UFC he's
the face of the UFC all the naysayers
all the people talking [__] to him
everyone thought Alex had his number I
don't have a problem with celebration
either I thought it was called for him
pointing at the sun was a little dicey
but if you remember he pointed at the
sun because the sun did that yeah when
Alex Pierre knocked him out in
kickboxing this is the initial that's
how he goes I'm Paddy man that's he
remembered that yep
nuts what a story only in mixed martial
arts do you get this [__] that was so
dope dude so even though it's a kid he
has to learn
hey yeah you know that's probably the
lowest point of Izzy's life so that's
the shitty part though the kid's crying
[Applause]
but that's the game
the kid's young though man that's a
bummer I hate to see that it sucks but
the kids should learn to not do that
kind of stuff you know
dude and that was years ago
that was what seven years ago it was a
long time ago
fantastic celebration the three arrows
all that [__] I loved it all
because I'm petty man yeah his son's
like this guy sucks
yeah his their dad got knocked out cold
yeah yeah he's all right though thank
God what else you got Jen
let's go to oh this is after the fight
as well this is really cool to watch
Israel and Alex Pereira
[Music]
um
thank you
everyone's all clapping yes I heard
that's King I heard that Alex wanted to
be Israel's friend but then he realized
that you know that's not happening it's
you know after the the three wins yeah
but he actually liked them he wanted to
be friends with them yeah it seems like
a good dude yeah yeah that poor guy
scary face right there I know you can
just tell the you know he's just his
heart's Broken Man
that's true but if you had three wins
over someone and they have one win over
you
wouldn't you still feel like
kind of badass hell yeah all right dude
yeah all right even if they don't fight
skin I'm still three and one exactly
yeah it's all good
you got me this done
boy did he get him though
and this isn't this was from Helen Yee I
guess this is Israel talking about a
potential opponent but he didn't give a
name
your words wisely but I don't want to
give no clown but if he does work and
pray to God he keeps winning I will
gladly drag his caucus across South
Africa while lying yeah but he's gonna
do this person in the comments because
he's either talking about Sean
Strickland or Hamza
no he's not no dude hey man he's talking
about homzot it's hard too that's what
he's talking about because you know with
the fan base there too don't get around
Hamlet's huge outside of America America
is getting bigger for sure but there's a
lot of hype on him but there's just
something you just can't go from not
being that active at 170 jumping up
fighting one of the greatest ever do it
who's coming off the biggest one in his
career he it just I know the UFC's crazy
and they do whatever makes money there
has to be some sort of [__] moral
standard here we can't do that yeah you
know what I'm saying like we can't do
that yeah
it doesn't even make sense I mean no
when he's saying this stuff Whitaker
makes sense yeah what Whitaker oh no I'm
saying like who he's talking about it
doesn't make sense it'll be Strickland
no it's definitely not strict that's
that's a stupid take
that was a horrible thing
uh this one I thought was very
interesting so this is
I'll just play it for you first
apparently this is Jon Jones and you'll
figure this out against Alex with
something else
I gotta hand it to you you've got some
serious skills in the Octagon but don't
think for a second that I forgot that
you ducked me when you grow a pair of
balls come see me at heavyweight kid you
said you would chase me up here while
I'm here now is this AI this is AI
congrats to my Nigerian but it sounds I
mean well it's gonna get so much better
later but it's gonna get better but
right I'm like
a little suspect I need a little suspect
congrats to my Nigerian brother
you said you know you said that you
would meet me at heavyweight well now
I'm at heavyweight
yeah but that was pretty interesting
um this is Gilbert Burns I know
he already won uh stuff but he was very
adamant about accusing Jorge Mazda of
using lotions because he was so slippery
like I'll just play this real quick some
guys rather cut weight they put oil into
the water yeah so it seeps into the skin
I I know those old tricks that those
guys do they you know what they do they
wake up on Sunday and they take the
first shower and they put past a lot of
lotion in your body yeah and the lotion
goes like this seeps into the skin the
skin absorbs it and you're super super
three hours you do it again and then
after you do it again then after you do
it again and your body absorbs whenever
it starts sweating a lot
Gilbert's a good guy too maybe he did it
doesn't really matter I know because he
like that because that he won and he
didn't really the the submission wasn't
there really uh in in retrospect
but he beat him you know yeah
and this is Dana going off on
reporters
any other stupid questions hilarious
okay
put WWE uh I'd rather not talk about
that right now talking about the you
know Endeavor purchasing
WWE
not that I have one more question for
Jorge oh hey yesterday
what was that about
absolutely nothing
you know there's there's nothing to talk
about there there's just some dick
riding Cloud chasing [__] you know so
ain't nothing to talk about
nah that's not what she was saying
yesterday bro watch your [__] mouth
Kevin I'm curious what appears what is
the issue there
I called him guys come on these two
aren't even fighting knock it off all
right okay well if you have a question
about the fight who these guys are
fighting I'm a date on this
anyways they kept going back to it and
then I think John Morgan asked the
question about it again and then Dan's
like any more oh no uh the Schmo asked
the question oh really yeah there's like
leaving more stupid questions
and then this another thing that Dana
did I will [__] attack did you see I
don't know if it's Photoshop you see a
picture of Dana in the hot tub no jacked
treadville population Dana
there's one oh my God no [__]
look at that food
it looks weird too in a way it'll slap
the [__] out of you
let me see the video
what the hell was that
here we go the reason I don't want you
guys talking about other fights is guys
we're [__] two days before a fight
he's not fighting Jorge Mazda I would
Dana whatever they got into whatever
first of all it creates [__] backstage
and at the hotels right when you guys
ask them questions like that and they
say something we still got two days
until the fight and these guys run into
each other backstage and everywhere else
and it's so disrespectful to their
opponent there's an opponent sitting up
there that they're gonna fight
and uh I I I just hate that [__] I get
it you want your [__] clicks or
whatever it is you guys want to get your
little [__] moment that you can post
but
I will [__] attack you if you do that
you know what I mean it's just it's just
uh causes a lot of [__] he's gonna
take you verbally
MMA joke he's doing it now I will
[__] attack you got it I'll post it
you know that's what he's talking about
yeah yeah I would date on this
um
you had your opinion on this the whole
Drake betting on it's all promotions
so he did win 2.7 million apparently for
this one that he bet less money like
before he bet more someone said like a
million dollars less I'm sure people are
like hey it's a little too obvious but
you're throwing seven million on the
under
card fight okay it's getting weird
and I get don't make it less obvious bet
like realistic but you're not too bad
don't bet seven billion dollars on page
fans at and bare knuckle
and they're both with that company too
Israel and Drake yeah
no I know a guy with uh psoriasis who
put a thousand on Izzy to win uh via
knockout and won ten thousand you know
guy I know a guy with psoriasis yeah
good work man so this is the fight
purses that are um
I don't know made public this is five
verses from green bird boxing four and
I'll just go to the main ones here
Jimmy Stevens 200k Jose Aldo 425 000
jock gray 200 Grand Vitor bell for 400k
no win bonus Roy Jones 700
650 no wind bonus
that's a lot of money right yeah yeah
it's boxing moment especially being an
early promotion you get scared when you
see those big numbers like you've seen
how this goes with Affliction but you
know Jorge smart team behind him too so
we'll see what's going on there but good
for them I like when Fighters get paid
yeah
and this is a uh the president of bkfc
talking about Francis agano you know
they obviously wanted him but he said
that Francis is asking for unrealistic
money so they passed on it yeah in the
longer this goes on where you me and
Cheeto alluded to it on the fight
campaign can available right now on
thick boy YouTube but
um the longer that no there's no news on
Francis the worst of this form the
hype's coming slowly coming down now I
think there is a world where you know
and we said Dana would never let him
back but Dana says a lot of things maybe
he would but I just don't know where
France is gonna go because
it made all the sense for him to leave
he said it was fighter right stuff like
that I don't know if it's that but he
you know I think the reason he left is
for the [__] you payday against the
Tyson Fury or Deontay Wilder and we
haven't heard much on that at all
especially from Deontay Wilder who's
ranked number one now by the way in WBC
I think he's number one so deante's
gonna make more money if he fights a
real boxing fight than what Francis so
you know you just have to hope for
Francis him leaving he does get one of
those big boxing fights but we haven't
heard anything on it at all so it's a
little scary for Francis then I'll say
that let let's say in this weird fight
world that we live in the Real
Housewives of the UFC this dramatic uh
show that we're part of let's say that
Francis doesn't get that box and fight
he has fine with MMA promotion where you
gonna go dude
where do you know that people give a
[__]
yeah where are you gonna go where are
you gonna go that you'd make more money
fighting whoever their Champion is then
you'd fight a Jon Jones
you know so it gets to icy for him the
long goes on we have to pray if your
friend's a fan that he does get that box
and fight because that would make it
valid for him leaving the UFC that
doesn't happen he just signs another
promotion disaster disaster absolute
disaster
yeah I know he uh raised stefo of the
pfl he said that they're in good talks
right now but
good talks doesn't mean like no
something's gonna happen the longer we
don't hear anything the worse it is for
Francis
because then outside out of mind
the fight came
yeah it's true
you know we every Monday we read current
[__] on the fight world yeah have you
when's the last time we did something on
Francis other than the stuff that we
talked about before yeah yeah
all right some about announcements
Amanda Nunez versus Juliana Pena three
this one doesn't make a ton of sense to
me either I don't anybody Chomp it at
the bit to see this Trilogy you know the
first fight Julia Pena did great it is a
good fight you know the second fight
it's pretty clear like there's times
where a fighter doesn't show up
overlooks opponent that opponent gets
one over I'm all good then when they do
the rematch in that person who's the
favorite beats the breaks off of them
like uh Amanda Nunez did then it's all
right that was a one-time thing no one's
really like man I'd love to see you the
third time I don't know anybody's like I
gotta stay on the third time I'm a huge
fan of penny I'm glad she's getting the
rematch but I just it doesn't make a ton
of sense but all right
and a pay-per-view headliner too tough
yeah tough so
especially after that last fight tough
tough self and that's for Canada
the Roger Center in Vancouver that's a
big boy Big Boy event Canada loves him
some sophisticuffs
let's see what they have so far
so obviously then that's a headliner
Stephen Thompson Michelle Pitt that's a
good one
nothing else really though
boy for UFC in Canada too come on man
you better you better give that thing
tasty stay well yeah that's in June I
think it's Junior yeah the the build
that up
all right uh that's June 10th
this is not loading but bow nickel is
gonna fight
trejon Gore
and here is
trejon Gore's record it's like four and
two
he was on The Ultimate Fighter I think
oh yeah I remember him Mr Vicious he's
four and two he's about to get his leg
snapped on
yeah I mean
all right feeding the monster Bo nickel
and then we'll go that's a tough one
because they're gonna do this he's gonna
Molly [__] this dude let's be real then
maybe do then then you'll give them like
a top 15 right outside top 15 that's Off
to the Races yeah
it's it's just like this you can feel
the pressure yeah and this unfortunately
Mr vicious is just part of the shrap
metal there you just get eaten a mauled
alive his coach is like oh God damn it
no no we'll figure it out man you can
always land one that's his coach dude
you land one this thing's over
um all right so a quick one let's go to
this Cory Anderson versus Phil Davis
that's tasty yeah
alrighty
and two more
but not let's skip this one but Misha
Tate she's gonna come back against
Myra Buena Silva and I'll show you their
records right now so this is Misha's
record yeah when she came back after how
many years a bunch of years she won and
then she won one she's lost last two
yeah
yeah but for her they're trying you know
they're trying to build this girl up
three three fight win streak it's a
massive name and this girl's a
submission artist Misha's submission
artist
I Like It Cool And since we're on Misha
she just posted this on Easter she was
great yep she looks awesome
and it's original dime the original dime
you think about it like she was she was
fighting before Rhonda yeah original
dime yep
and this is
hold on the headline here I mean the the
subject says Darren till anticipates
boxing next I would just run over Logan
Paul and Tommy Fury that's true so yeah
well he's basically saying that he if he
were to go to another promotion so pfl
actually hit him up one hit him up
honestly I thought he was taking a break
from MMA exactly better yeah so they hit
him up and he's like if I did something
like that it would be disrespectful to
your C but if I did boxing it would be
cool he said he would actually do a
boxing match though if the money was
right so let's say that I don't get it
either too much so but but what happened
to
you know he's leaving the UFC so he can
get some proper uh stuff which I'm all
for I'm I'm with him on the smart do you
know you do that then you get back in
the testing pool after you you know
recover but it it would depend on the
commission if they just allow you to
take you know these perform performance
enhancing drugs if he's doing the boxing
thing I'm sure he can get around that
though right I would assume yeah
and I doubt Logan Paul or Tommy fear is
going to take that fight Tommy Fury
versus Darren till would be fantastic
build up that'd be great especially in
over in London yeah they would love that
I love that
a little British on Brit crime hell yeah
all right almost done here these are
some highlights from one that I thought
were cool
a sec oh I'll be at the May uh was it
may fifth fight in Denver Colorado
they won championships flying your boy
out
nice that's DJ right yep rematch Thor
trilogy trilogy all right so
this is uh
two guys getting knocked down
hardness damn
[Music]
hey
it's fine
six seven step forward step forward step
forward
oh my God
oh he's a little wobby he's a I'm good
too
crazy they just popped back up yeah
little guys man
and this one is helbos from Mark
abellardo
oh
bro he hit him so hard when that was he
fell over yeah
Jesus Christ elbows
if Mark uh if that Mark was
able orado or ablorado if his nickname's
not hell bows elbows like Hellboy
yeah is that it dude there's one more
this is just my period this happened oh
I saw this press conference my channel
wipes his nose on uh is that a really he
said it was a it was like his fancy
brand that's a fan I mean he was a model
it's too puffy for me it looks awkward
like are they fighting in Montana
[Music]
he fix his nose
all right
that's funny yeah that's pretty much it
all right dude well yeah the UFC's just
cranking them out you had a great fight
night coming up one of the greatest to
ever do at Max Holly Arnold Allen that
fight it's fantastic this could be on a
pay-per-view all day co-main event we're
gonna find out what Arnold Allen's made
of man this is it the undefeated Arnold
Allen testing the waters against Max
Holloway and you're out of your mind I
think Max Holloway is over the hill or
anything like that Max always a [__]
Savage I can't wait Barboza Billy I'll
take Billy all goddamn day on that fight
Dustin Jacoby's doing the damn thing uh
Tanner Bowser's on there Pedro Munoz
clay Guida he has some Throwbacks you
have Clay Guida and Ed Hermann on that
card Brandon Roy Val on the undercard
how dare you that's offensive uh
venada's fighting great card for a fight
night
I'll definitely be watching it in the
Green Room in Atlanta it's gonna be on
late in Atlanta what's that it's a 5 p.m
here so that's 8 P.M there yeah so I
should be able to see some of the main
card by the time I get on stage but I'll
be watching The Green Room Atlanta come
on out this Thursday Friday Saturday
punch line Atlanta come shake that dirty
bird and I'll begin my wings at Magic
City come get you some Atlanta this
Thursday Friday Saturday and June 2nd
through the 4th is La Jolla Comedy Store
and I'm jumping all over the pond
Belfast June 15th Glasgow June 17th
Manchester June 18th London June 22nd
Cardiff June 23rd Dublin I end in Dublin
my favorite place Dublin June 25th
who's this is a theater run one show
only in every single City that I just
listed so get your tickets now at
thickboy.com that's it kids love you
until next time uh enjoy the fights on
Saturday thanks for liking uh please
subscribe like watch everything love you
guys be safe I'm out